for an undercover operation to target
sex trafficking
specifically by arresting pimps who are
forcing women to sell sex vanessa murphy
has this exclusive report you'll only
see here
on 8 news now
[Music]
this is memorial day weekend and while
visitors enjoy the las vegas strip
there are a lot of criminals and a lot
of
and there's a lot of nefarious activity
going down on the strip jim where you
going
this team at metro police headquarters
we have a mission
it's ready to address a dark underbelly
of the glitz and glam
welcome everybody to i think what's
going to be
the largest human actual human
trafficking operation we've ever done
lieutenant william matchgo heads the
vice section we're here tonight because
memorial day weekend attracts
a great deal of traffickers to the
valley arrest reports obtained by the
eye team point to a rise in violent and
prostitution related crimes on las vegas
boulevard
sex traffickers seize that opportunity
to come in and sell people matchko tells
the i-team busy weekends with holidays
or special events
attract pimps bringing in prostitutes
across state lines
especially from california metro is
teaming up with federal agencies to
target
the pimps police will work both in
uniform and undercover
i'll just be walking through the casino
floor and wait for
pimps to come up and approach me this
officer will be posing as a prostitute
they usually start out by complimenting
us telling us
asking us what we're doing out there
they go on to just tell us how we can do
better and how they can help us
but what she describes is a broken
promise
they go after children they go after
vulnerable women
they're just extremely violent people
they enslave them in 2020 metro
identified 128
adult victims of sex trafficking meaning
they were forced or coerced to sell sex
the department also identified 123
victims
under the age of 18. in this eight-year
study of child sex trafficking in las
vegas
922 child victims were identified
we have some of the highest numbers of
recoveries in the
nation every single year and that
included last year during kovid
which is actually surprising as well
because
you would think with the shutdown of
tourism prostitution and
sex trafficking would slow down but it
did not
and he says sex trafficking is connected
to other crime
theft against people buying sex also
known as trick rolls
pimp turf wars and according to metro
about
half of the alleged pimps arrested are
linked to gangs
it's just another challenge with being a
major tourist destination
this vehicle can help us out on our
undercover operations
on this saturday night there's a command
post cameras show different angles and
several teams are at work while the eye
team is embedded
they can plan the entire response from
this vehicle
a total of 14 arrests are reported
lieutenant matchko says
three are suspected pimps in one case
metro police say a suspect told an
officer posing as a prostitute
he wanted half of her earnings
threatened to choke her and became
territorial with another pimp
if i can go out there and make that
arrest and put them in prison and
prevent them
from doing this to an actual victim then
at the end of the day
i've done my job and her work continues
the i-team has learned police are
maintaining contact with four others who
continue to reach out to
undercover detectives to try to recruit
them into prostitution
vanessa murphy 8 news news